only on CBS this morning the widow of a
murdered detective speaks out for the
first time since giving birth to his
daughter two years after he died
a gunman ambushed and killed New York
City police officer wenjian liu and his
partner in december 2014 through in
vitro fertilisation Lou's wife delivered
a baby girl just last week she shared
her story with Jeff Glor Jeff good
morning Margaret good morning Sonny and
wenjian liu were newlyweds married just
three months when she got the call her
husband with shots they've been planning
to start a family
and she thought of that plan during that
awful time when she saw her husband at
the hospital when I was sitting there
and I and he was he was just after the
death of her husband on that horrible
night when he was assassinated inside a
police cruiser
Sani liu says she knew this day would
come
I had a dream I had a babies quiet and
handing me the baby
he said Timmy has the baby he's a girl
you dreamed about him handing you a baby
that night the same knife it was a girl
right NYPD Commissioner James O'Neill
was at the hospital he remembers sandy
asking if doctors could preserve her
husband's sperm they didn't know if it
was gonna work they didn't know if it
was
gonna be a possibility and here it is
two and a half years later and it's uh
it's a miracle that is he's seen the
heaven right now but he always looked
after us Sani tells us she proceeded
with IVF to honor her late husband I
want him to had a child to carry on his
legacy because laughing i won me with a
child do you want her to be a police
officer it's up to her it's up to her
would you like to see her be a police
officer
of course that's that's brave that's
that's she's a courageous woman and it's
a great job when Jen lose daughter will
one day learn all about his dedication
to the job Sani says she'll pass on this
necklace with his badge number so it can
always be close to her heart I'll show
my daughter that her father was a hero
her father and me mega ultimate
sacrifice to make this whoa a safer
place the baby's name is Angelina yes
why is that she's that not only angel
from heaven she's the angel for the NYPD
for all the police officers I hope
she'll bring all the hope and strength
to my big blue family the big blue
family big blue family so now you have
an angel for your husband and for and
for the big blue family yes I hope
things bring the strength and hope to
everybody as you can see both mom and
daughter are doing very well sandy did
not rule out the possibility of giving
little Angelina a brother or sister in
the future amazing about this story is
that she asked for it she did yeah that
night she said she just knew they didn't
know if it would work it did not two and
a half years later they are a joy to be
around
enjoy she is so happy the baby's so
happy the baby's not sleeping at night
at all but they are they're just a joy
to spend time with such a big story
thank you Jeff